dans tous les lieux touchés par les
attentats le même geste
le même hommage giroud prix causé ni ce
recueil puis la minute de silence
nous ne les oublierons pas 130 morts des
centaines de blessés
alors d'abord pour leur mémoire mais
aussi pour tous ceux qui ont survécu et
pour lesquels nous devons faire cet acte
de souvenirs qui ne peux pas m'empêcher
de penser qu'il a une part de
responsabilité dans ce qui s'est passé
et qui ne prépare pas la france à ce qui
risque de se passer dans les mois qui
viennent donc oui nous allons vivre
encore sans doute pendant quelques mois
avec cet état d'urgence et surtout nous
allons vivre avec cette menace j'espère
qu'elle va progressivement diminuer
je souhaite au fond qu'on mette en
rétention administrative tous les
fichiers s dont les services de
renseignement nous devrons indiquer leur
dangerosité risque de 2007 à 2012 sur le
gouvernement françois fillon on a
profondément réformé en france une
question qui se pose
la réponse est là concernant la réponse
est très mitigé très très mitigé donc il
ne suffit pas de dire je suis fort je
vais faire des réformes pour convaincre
je suis crédible parce que je suis
sérieux et que je le pouvais les médias
ont bien le droit de publier des
sondages mais il ya une chose qu'ils
n'ont pas le droit de faire il ya une
chose qu'ils n'ont pas le droit de faire
c'est d'installer dans l'esprit des
français
l'idée que les autres candidats n'ont
aucune chance de gagner les élections
parce que ça c'est contraire à la
démocratie
c'est très rassurant de reprendre les
mêmes on les connaît ils n'ont pas fait
forcément très bien le boulot
non non ça qu'on a à faire moi ce que je
propose c'est de transformer totalement
notre système par themaa différence avec
les autres candidats que ce soit nicolas
sarkozy que ce soit françois fillon ou
quelques autres ils ne veulent pas
augmenter les effectifs de police de
gendarmerie de magistrats deux gardiens
de prison c'est aujourd'hui le l'enjeu
majeur quand j'entends un certain nombre
de clean de mes candidats vouloir
asséner des remèdes de cheval à notre
pays
et bien c'est aux animaux on donne des
remèdes de cheval ce n'est pas aux
sociétés humaines
n'accepte pas que lorsque 58 millions
d'électeurs américains votent pour
donald trump
on se bouche le nez en disant c'est le
populisme
le peuple a tort parce que pour moi le
papelard et de revoir interrogé au sujet
de l'obamacare le président et lui
revient sur sa promesse de supprimer
totalement cette loi qui a donné une
assurance santé à 22 millions
d'américains dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi déjà une manifestation avait
dégénéré résultat 26 personnes
interpellées des vitrines brisées et des
voitures endommagées
elle sera abrogée et remplacée il y aura
un grand système d'assurance santé qui
coûtera beaucoup moins cher voire à new
york une centaine de personnes arpentent
la ville en passant par la tour trump et
times square